et pour raconter la télé il ya 40 ans on
va regarder ce qui s'est passé entre le
lundi 5 janvier et le dimanche 11
janvier 1976 cette semaine là le pdg de
phonogrammes louis hazan qui avait été
enlevé et séquestré et retrouvé par les
enquêteurs dans un pavillon dans le
département de l'eure et loire à tours
au centre ville
les bus sont décidément très électrique
enfin au clos lucé chez léonard de vinci
la joconde tenez vous bien parle au
visiteur savoir c'est pour ça qu'on est
là d'ailleurs le journal de la semaine
ça commence maintenant
téléspectateurs descente bon ce pas il y
ait la stase et françois jauffret
orléans ce n'était pas un rêve mais la
réalité
on commence donc avec une drôle
d'histoire louis hazan le pdg de
phonogrammes une filiale de philips et
enlevés fin décembre 75 puis séquestrée
ici pendant sept jours dans cette
propriété située dans la beauce l'une
des questions que l'on se pose ici à
trembler le vicomte est effectivement de
savoir pourquoi les ravisseurs ont jeté
leur dévolu sur cette petite commune de
la loire sur cette demeure située au
numéro 24 de la route d'achères les
policiers m'ont raconté un peu ce qu'ils
avaient fait quoi évidemment ils ont
monté sur le portail et ils ont trouvé
monsieur avant a donc été là peu de
temps après les faits les ravisseurs ont
été arrêtés jugés et condamnés
sauf un et tenez vous bien il est resté
en cavale pendant 19 ans avant de se
constituer prisonnier en 1994
mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là il
n'a été jugé que six ans plus tard soit
en 2000 vous me suivez toujours
jugez donc en 2000 et il a écopé d'une
peine de prison avec sursis car la
justice a estimé qu'il s'agissait là
d'une erreur de jeunesse
il est donc ressorti libre à l'issue de
son procès
en fait il existe six véhicules de ce
type construit par edf et sauve elle qui
pour l'instant sont à l'état de
prototype des bus électriques au centre
ville de tours
un test grandeur nature sur 5 km une
expérience voulue par jean royer mais
abandonné deux ans plus tard car c'était
une galère pour les conducteurs dans
chaque bus il y avait quatre tonnes de
batteries et les châssis était lourd
enfin tenez vous bien les bus électrique
pollue et si si car en hiver ils étaient
chauffés au fioul pour ne pas consommer
trop d'électricité
cqfd tom elisabetta canalis n'a pu
résister au clos lucé à amboise
figurez vous que la joconde parle c'est
pas un gag
jean-françois bonjour flavien bienvenu
que le sait merci à vous françois saint
bris directeur donc du clos lucé ici à
amboise on l'a entendu dans le reportage
en 1976 la joconde parle aux touristes
oui c'est frais c'est formidable parce
qu'on connaît le sourire de mona lisa
mais on ignore qu'elle parle donc c'est
une innovation technologique
extraordinaire qui je crois a été
réalisée par des japonais
on a vu ces images avec le magnéto à
bang qui restituait leçon on va écouter
quelques réactions de visiteurs nous
avons eu la surprise d'entendre savoir
naturellement on ne peut pas juger si
c'est vraiment la voix de mona lisa
mais enfin ça c'est un grand honneur
pour nombre amboise de penser que c'est
peut-être la loi de manas lisant le
jugement d'une femme est toujours
intéressant surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de
la voie d'une autre femme
alors quel est votre avis madame écouter
la fois de mona lisa est très belle elle
s'accorde très bien avec son visage mais
est ce bien la réalité seuls léonard
pourrait nous le dira à la fin des
années 2000 autre expérience que là vous
connaissez bien expérience multimédia
réalisée là encore par des japonais on a
entendu la voix de mona lisa à nouveau
ici au clos lucé
leonardo me enquête au pénal oui alors
ça effectivement c'était lors d'une
exposition réalisée ici en 2007 nous
avions une innovation technologique
différentes
c'était en que la joconde qui qui
parlait et qui nous disait bienvenue au
clos lucé je m'appelle mona lisa là on a
vu qu'on n'avait pas uniquement le sens
on avait aussi l'image en élevage et
effectivement cette image qui parlait la
joconde part est-ce que la joconde que
l'on voit dans le reportage d'actualité
de l'époque est la même que celle qui se
trouve juste juste à côté de nous oui
c'est la même cette joconde est une des
dix copies qui ont été réalisées après
la mort de léonard de vinci et celle ci
est une copie réalisée par le peintre du
roi henri iv qui s'appelle ambroise du
bois quels sont les projets pour le clos
lucé
pour cette nouvelle année 2016 alors
2016 est une grande année pour nous
puisque nous allons commémorer l'arrivée
de leonardo vinci en france et nous
allons proposer au grand public une
grande exposition dont le thème sera du
clos lucé au lourd les trois chefs
d'oeuvre de léonard de vinci
merci à vous françois au revoir fin
bientôt
on termine ce journal de la semaine avec
une image image de deux stars du tennis
de l'époque
ilie nastase le roumain ancien numéro un
mondial est connu pour ses facéties et
françois jauffret numéro un français il
s'agissait là d'une exhibition qui se
déroulait à orléans tout ça pour vous
dire que dans pile deux mois l'équipe de
france de tennis affrontera le canada à
l'occasion du premier tour de la coupe
davis avec le retour de noah aux
manettes à la semaine prochaine